Hillary Clinton just weighed in on the
heat wave that we're experiencing and
she said quote hot enough for you thank
a Maga Republican or better yet vote
them out of office
Hillary Clinton you know she's the adult
in charge she's the really serious
person and this very serious person is
saying that summer heat waves
a feature of life for all of history
are the fault of Republicans and not
those Mitt Romney Republicans by the way
not those nice little Republicans who
Swish and help out the Democrats the mag
are Republicans the conservatives
conservatives are responsible for the
weather
I thought the last theory on that was
that the Jews controlled the weather
wasn't that that was the last conspiracy
theory now sorry Jews you're out it's
the Maga Republicans who control the
weather now I don't know when we get our
space lasers when's Hillary gonna start
talking about the Maga Republican space
laser I don't know it's just as crazy a
theory though we
we don't control the weather we don't
control the heat it's been hot in July
forever and uh Donald Trump is not
responsible for that at all I mentioned
this story not to point out that Hillary
Clinton is a very silly lady not to
point out that the libs are far crazier
than the conservatives are all of that
obviously we just take that for granted
the thing I want to point out here
is a trick of the libs which is that the
libs are very good at appealing to the
Flesh and conservatives are not as good
at that conservatives are really good at
making logical arguments conservatives
are really good at destroying people
with facts and logic and making all
sorts of intellectual and historical and
philosophical points sure the libs are
really good at appealing to the Flesh
and they do this through all sorts of
decadent temptations that they make
obviously the sexual Revolution
obviously the drugs obviously all those
kinds of things we see but even here
even in this silly Hillary Clinton tweet
she says hey are you feeling hot right
now do you feel uncomfortable are you
sweating yeah that's Republican's fault
does that make any sense no they come up
with some tenuous Preposterous argument
you know well actually because the
Republicans drive cars like we all do
and Republicans use oil like everyone on
earth does that some that because of
that and the oil anger is the sun
monster and the sun monster shines as
Rays even more strongly and the climate
catastrophe warming cooling change
whatever that's that's the but the
argument is secondary what what is
primary is the appeal to the flesh
and so because they can speak in this
fleshy kind of language and appeal to
your your base or appetites and appeal
to your sensation they forage that
connection such that when completely
unrelated events happen when the water
goes up when the water goes down when
the ice breaks off when there's too much
ice when there's a hurricane when
there's not a hurricane whenever
anything happens in the weather and you
feel it you have that connection in
there it's it's irrational but so much
of politics is based on sentiment you
know a friend and colleague of mine
likes to say facts don't care about your
feelings politics largely cares about
your feelings and the libs get that a
lot better than conservatives do and so
we can all mock Hillary's argument it
will have a lot of currency for a lot of
people right now head on over to
goodranchers.com promo code Knowles you
know I love anything made with top of
the line quality for meat it is good
ranchers simple as that the only thing
that was missing from good ranchers
truly this was my only complaint about
good Ranchers but I did complain about
this to sweet little Elisa
they were missing some pork
and I like well
let me tell you something when you ask
for for things good ranchers delivers
good ranchers has just launched their
Prime pork 100 American pork that is
Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone-in and boneless pork
chops sausage smoked brats and more plus
right now you get 30 bucks off with code
Knowles at goodranchers.com on their
site you can explore their All-American
cuts of prime pork Prime Beef and better
than organic chicken options if you've
tried their beef and chicken before then
you know how amazing it is you've got to
try the prime pork at least once they
have got genuinely great products and
talked to your customer service I love
it my only thing that I'm really missing
now while I'm traveling in Hungary other
than my wife and children is my good
ranchers when I go home in a sweet
little Elisa three times a week makes me
juicy delicious steak and one of the
last meals I had before I left was was a
good ranch's Burger it's the best it's
like the best burger I've ever had in my
life what are you waiting for go to
goodranchers.com code Knowles 30 bucks
off any box
goodranchers.com promo code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s goodranches.com Amer
American Meat delivered the former San
Francisco D.A Chase of Boudin you
remember him he's the guy that allowed
San Francisco to just turn into a
complete cesspit of Filth and excrement
and dead druggies and criminals and it's
just you can't even really travel there
anymore so that guy finally got booted
out of office that was great and now
he's making over 200 Grand a year in a
position at UC Berkeley of course
and the Harvard law professor Adrian
vermeul great conservative intellectual
today he pointed out that what this is
is basically a sign a cure for failed
leftists
and it's something the left does very
well and the right is not really good at
it
and it's important it's not just a way
to take care of your buddies it's a way
to encourage further activism because on
the left right now what we are what the
what the leftists are told not what we
are told what the leftists are told is
hey go out there be radical push our
crazy policies and I know it might not
be popular but you'll probably be able
to hold on to power and don't worry if
you don't hang on to power
we got your back don't worry you're
never going to miss a meal you're never
going to go broke okay
because if you push it too far we're
going to support that and then if you do
get thrown out of office don't worry
you'll make 200 plus Grand a year
in some post what is he doing at UC
Berkeley
he's going to run the new center that
was just founded the criminal law and
Justice Center at this public university
so your taxpayer dollars at least
California's taxpayer dollars here
and boudin says that the center is going
to give them better opportunity to
create lasting progress through public
service so the university is going to
pay him 210 Grand a year and they've
said that they're going to fund the
center
four hundred thousand dollars for the
next three years now that number is
important
is that number for a whole Center is
nothing
the university is releasing this as
we're giving four hundred thousand
dollars to the set what are you going to
do with 400 000 you're gonna run a
center for three years
you're paying more than half of that in
the salary to the the failed leftist da
heading it
why because the point of hiring him was
not so that you would have someone to
run this important center it's the
opposite you created the center to give
this guy a paycheck the center is
nothing it's not maybe he'll go out and
raise outside money I'm sure he could
he's plugged into pretty wealthy donors
but it doesn't matter the center could
have one office and one chair he doesn't
even need to show up to it it's just a
way to say hey when you fail we got you
so all you other leftists sat there
don't be afraid of trying to radically
implement our agenda the right doesn't
really do that the right does it a
little bit on the neocon squishy liberal
side
I'm not going to name the think tanks
and the institutions I think you know
the ones we're talking about though a
lot of the never Trumper types went over
there when they got booted out of GOP
politics they just go and they collect
their six-figure paycheck and they
publish white papers that nobody reads
and they Lament The Fall of the GOP or
whatever then it doesn't matter
because they in many ways are are just
as much upholders as the liberal
establishment as the radical leftists
like boudinor the difference is that the
role of these squishy conservatives is
to be the court Jesters in the Kingdom
of liberalism so their their role is to
provide a semblance of opposition so it
looks as though there's a real political
fight going on that looks as though
there's a real representation for the
people but there's not
their job is to lose with dignity that's
why they support the candidates who lose
that's not a that's not a flaw of their
system that's the feature of their
system but but in terms of the actual
conservatives
the real they call it I don't know the
populist right or maybe the traditional
right or the conservative writer
whatever the guys who are actually
conservative we don't really have that
if we fail we're kind of in trouble
financially at least and maybe there are
some ways that you can you can parlay
your your work into some other but
it's nothing like the Liberals habits
and and the right needs to build that up
part of how the left has been so
effective at implementing its radical
agenda is it has mitigated the potential
downside for trying to do it
the conservative right needs to do the
same thing boy what a great clip that
was now hold on ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time